show by substitution into why show by
substitution into why that the Apple is
in the air for less than one second okay
I leave my diagram there excuse me how
do I work out how long the apples in the
air it'll be it'll be from this point
that's when it starts it's in the air
this whole time until y equals zero
again right so if I solve for y equals
zero okay
that'll give me obviously it'll give me
the starting point because I started
zero but are also giving the input in
terms of time right so here we go here's
my crazy right minus 5t squared plus 2 5
t that's equal to zero I can factorize
it's that okay there yep look at that
Navy okay so now I've got my two
solutions for tea right here's my zero
solution my starting point right and
what's my other solution it'll be two or
five on five win it this time this guy
yeah and as it happens
he's already rationalized that's nice
that's just kind of lucky okay so what's
this value it's zero or now you have to
show that it's less than a second right
so you have to get out your calculator
and you have to chuck the number in and
I think we all get what you get you get
the same values maybe yeah good okay
so at this point you've watched your
home is but you need to all it's all
right so you would say Adam catches the
Apple anyway
when hey I didn't like the question of
when T equals zero point eight nine
right so it's in the apples in the air
for less than a second that's all you
need
okay question yes/no said again oh
because that's what they asked us to
prove that's all show by substitution
into why that the Apple is in the air
for less than one second that's all and
I guess depending on what other kind of
what kind of initial velocity either
being in the air for a different time by
the way that's kind of cool because now
do you remember how we um did that
exercise outside right we did this
exercise and we were all trying to make
guesses and we did recordings and like
that kind of thing well clearly this
means if I know this if I wanted to
could I work backwards to get to my
initial velocity goodnight I could do
that right so you'd be able to work out
actually how hard you can throw a ball
in meters per second that's kind of neat
anyway okay now Part D find the greatest
height above the point of release
reached by the Apple find the greatest
height where is it it's gonna be up here
right that's the greatest height which
corresponds to your axis of symmetry
right so if I know what the time is here
at this end point all I have to do to
get to the maximum is to take off of
that I don't want it to do so let's do
that when the time is half of that root
5 over 5 that's 105 isn't it okay and I
want to know what the height is so which
of my equations of which I have many is
the relevant one it's why good vertical
displacement so I've got this
I can't where's my question here it is
there it is so I've got minus five one
on Route five squared plus 2 root 5
times 100
said all right what happens in you
simple numbers cuz they chose a simple
situation for us okay putt e we've
already done half all party they say
show that the flat time is two or five
on five well we've done that that's fine
but then they ask us to find the
horizontal distance traveled by the
Apple that's this distance how do I do
that
I'm doing the same thing right but I'm
not subbing into y minus M into X I'm
just leaving this here because I need my
horizontal displacement equation right
so I can say this is my final point in
the motion of the Apple so I'm going to
check it in and because it's 3/5 and
root 5 you just get used to don't you
they good two meters away from each
other
easy right okay fine x dot y dot at the
time Apple
it's like Apple and it's like Adam
catches the Apple okay how do I do that
I do that what am i up to
I think I'm up to F how do you find X
dot and Y dot for the final point in
time
well again I'm gonna look at my exit
equation and my y dot equation which
I've rubbed off which i think is
something like minus 10 T plus 2/5 I
think for a memory ok so you're going to
pop in your final time into both of
these
ok that'll give you X dot y dot but what
they really want to show is the second
part use the velocity resolution diagram
to show the final speed speed don't care
about Direction sure the final speed
equals the initial speed hmm have a look
at this by the way you can kind of see
it country there's this symmetry about
the diagram because it's a problem that
you're getting this kind of situation in
here in Reverse right
so therefore in terms of speed they will
be the same because I don't worry about
directly
okay so go through with me how I set
this out I'm gonna take this time right
and I'm gonna pop it into here and here
to get my exponent why don't we can do
this in our heads can't we tell me what
X that is 5 root 5 it's it's a constant
why not
this is gonna be it'll be minus 4 root 5
plus 2 5 months where it tells the -20
on for I think and that's minus 2 5 can
you see what's happening right
horizontal ASSA t hasn't changed whole
situation because of this right vertical
varsity is exactly what you started with
but in the opposite direction of course
it is because it's coming to land right
so now when you do your diagram this
diagram is a crucial part of it okay
okay
now the apples coming down like so right
so here's your X dot and he's your Y
goal which is negative okay
but of course Pythagoras squares
everything else it's just down so when
you get this speed here it's still going
to be 5 right
okay now important the moon I got a
question about this at the end of
yesterday's lesson you've got two angles
in this situation now this question
talks about excuse me the final angle of
inclination stop angle of inclination
where is that on this diagram now I
think the final angle of inclination is
here I think that's the angle B
inclination you do it from the
horizontal and you figure out how far
you have to look up right that's an
angle of inclination that's what they're
asking for in this case it would be
negative 10 inverse of to negative 63 or
whatever you can crunch the numbers you
can see right but there's another angle
here it has a different name this is the
angle of inclination but the other angle
which they will ask for just as often is
not the angle of inclination of course
because you're not looking up at this
point you're you're doing Pilates at
this point okay this is called the angle
of impact
it's obtuse right unless you fire in the
opposite direction it almost certainly
has to be abused right so if they asked
for the angle of inclination this is
what they're after
or alternatively the angle of elevation
same thing okay but the angle of impact
right come back to the circle by
convention when we're measuring angles
like this we always measure from which
point where's zero no seriously where is
the zero angle it's from the positive
side this side of the x-axis right the
positive side you don't measure over
here it's not enough just to say from
the horizontal it has to be from a
direction at the horizontal right so the
same way your angle of impact is from
the positive side of the x-axis okay
so note for that because they'll ask you
different things another expecting
different angle okay I guess it would be
if they did ask for it here beyond 117
thereabouts you get the idea it's to say
with my point okay